j'accueille à présent sur ce plateau
elles sont en train de s'installer
Pascal Camu chargé de communication du
parc naturel de la Haute Vallée de
Chevreuse bonsoir et Vanessa Reyes
mercado bonsoir artiste connu sous le
nom de vanan si j'ai bien prononcé et
nous allons parler des métiers d'art à
présent du 5 au 7 avril des Journées
Européennes leur sont consacré nous
avons aussi en ligne ce soir
Marie-Hélène Frémont
bonsoir bonsoir marie-lène Frémont
directrice générale de l'Institut des
Métiers d' bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes en
ligne avec nous et tout simplement merci
et cette première question comment se
définit un métier d'art un métier d'art
c'est une technique c'est maîtrise d'une
technique appliqué à la transformation
de la matière pour produire un objet en
pièce unique ou en petite série qui est
à la fois beau et utile il y a plus de
200 métiers réparti en 19
sect7 et 19
secteurs 19 secteurs qui se voilà qui se
définissent par matériaux bois verre
métal
terre puis puis vous avez aussi tous les
métiers qui sont liés au spectacle voilà
les l'art floral le textile c'est
effectivement organisé par famille de
matériaux alors que vont permettre ces
journées
Européennes alors ces journées servent à
mettre en valeur en évidence en lumière
tous ces métiers qui sont une véritable
richesse pour notre pays qui font partie
du patrimoine immatériel de notre pays
mais
attention changeons de regard sur ces
métiers ce sont pas des métiers du passé
ce sont les métiers de l'avenir qui
s'attuent certes sur des pratiques et
parfois des techniques ancestrales mais
qui sont grâce à l'innovation à la
création de ceux qui les pratiquent sont
des métiers d'avenir et totalement
innovant
aujourd'hi reçu justement de que de se
dire que ce sont des des métiers du
passé c'est une idée reçue qui qui
revient encore souvent c'est une idée
que l'on combat forctement euh qui peut
être qui peut exister encore comme comme
on a des préjugés sur les métiers de la
main on a des préjugés sur les métiers
d'art en disant bon il sont des vieux
métiers euh certes qui ont contribué à
faire de la France un pays phare dit
temp 2011 mais qui ont aujourd'hui pas
qui n'ont plus leur place or c'est faux
aujourd'hui dans le monde entier on
vient chercher l'excellence française
euh les même les maisons de luxe ne
vivraient pas sur les métiers d'arts et
tous les jeunes que l'on voit arriver
dans ces métiers créent des entreprises
sont capables d'innover d'être
extrêmement créatifs et d'avoir une
offre qui est euh tout à fait compétitif
dans l'économie de la création alors
juste une dernière question ce sont des
Journées européennes pour promouvoir ces
ces métiers d' et à travers ce que vous
nous dites on comprend bien que la
France a une place à part au milieu de
ces ces autres pays européens alors là
la France et leadership pour être très
clair nous avons initié ces journées
elles étaient en 2011 national en 2012
elles ont commencé à être européennes et
elles sont en
2013 véritablement européennes puisque
neuf autres pays nous ont rejoint à
l'initiative de la France c'est-à-dire
sur le modèle franaé nous sommes moteurs
en la matière parce que reconnu comme la
patrie des métiers de l'excellence et
des métiers d'art et notre initiative à
à trouver un écho dans la plupart des
pays européens qui se retrouvait dans la
même problématique c'est-à-dire comment
valoriser leur savoir-faire
d'excellence merci Marie-Hélène Frémont
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous
directrice générale de l'Institute des
métiers d'art ces métiers d'art on va
continuer à en parler sur ce plateau je
me tourne à présent vers vous Pascal
Camu en charge donc de la communication
pour le parc naturel de la haute Vallé
de Chevreuse dans les ivelines on
recense presque une centaine
d'événements pour ces fameuses journées
qui débutent le 5 avril une grande
partie se déroule en Vallée de Chevreuse
justement c'est une vraie richesse de ce
parc naturel oui tout à fait on essaie
de d'exploiter le patrimoine local et le
parc toute façon c'est investi depuis
des années auprès des artisans d'art et
à cette occasion nous ouvrons le chuteau
de Madeleine qui est le parc qui est le
siège du parc pour accueillir donc des
artisans d'art et nous avons notamment
quelqu'un qui effectue des meubles en
carton et du patchwork et aussi les
écoactions qui en fait recyclent des
bâes et font des sacs et bah différents
petits accessoires donc parmi les
différents événements qui sont organisés
des portes ouvertes directement chez les
différents artisans qui vont prouver
présenter leur métier et puis vous
l'avez dit le château de La Maline qui
sera ouvert il y a aussi ces ces
randonné puisque vous proposez des
promenades aussi dans le parc pour aller
à la rencontre de ces différents
artisans promenade pédestre promenade à
vélo également durant le weekend c'est 7
avril tout le dimanche 7 avril donc on
offre le parc offre les 20 premières
places aux inscrits donc pour cela en
fait vous avez toute la documentation
sur
wwpar-naturel-chevreuse.fr et également
des balades pédestres entre la Fondation
Coubertin qui ouvre ses portes
exceptionnellement pour la première fois
cette année pour cette occasion et
chevreuson et comment on explique cette
richesse du parc naturel sur ces métiers
d'art et ben écoutez nous sont prés
depuis des décennies des décennies tout
à fait et puis nous avons un patrimoine
local notamment des châteaux et cetera
qui ont fait que beaucoup d'artisans se
sont lancés dans cette
activité nous avons également un
justement un jeune artisan d'art qui
ouvre ses portes un ferronier maréchal
férant à Lévi saintnon qui pour cette
occasion va accueillir le public petit
et grands ils sont plutôt preneurs
justement de de ces opérations
tout pardon
allez- tout à fait parce que ce sont
souvent des talents entre guillemets
cché parce que maréchal ferrand
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y en a très
peu et ils sont pas très connus et je
pense que bon c'est une bonne sortie ce
weekend pour en profiter mais on a
également comme le disait la directrice
de l'Institut des personnes aussi qui
essaye d'innover en faisant justement à
base de matériaux recyclés des choses
qui peuvent nous servir dans la vie de
tous les jours et tout ça ce sera
découvrir du côté du parc naturel de la
Haute Vallée de Chevreuse nous parlons
des métiers d'art dans le 78 ce soir les
Journées européennes qui débutent le 5
avril pour 3 B jour nous avons une de
ces artistes sur le plateau bonsoir à
vous vanan c'est votre nom d'artiste
alors vous n'êtes pas en Vallé de
Chevreuse vous êtes juste à côté vous
êtes du côté de de Guill en cour
d'origine vénézuélienne installé depuis
5 ans et vous réalisez notamment des
bijoux pouvez nous en dire plus sur
votre travail vous êtes venu avec
quelques-unes des réalisations oui tout
à fait et j'ai
apporté mes produits en fait j'ai la
supporte aussi et ils font partie de de
mes créations
et je normalement je trouve que que la
la femme d'aujourd'hui elle cherche elle
cherche l'originalité et mais mais aussi
la simplicité et bon j'ai fait un peu de
de variété partout et je suis bon en
fait mon nom le nom de l'entreprise
s'appelle création et ça fait partie de
un ensemble création décoration et et la
ti événuel et et bon en cette occasion
je vous remercie l'invitation et et la
journée européen de métier nous donne
l'opportunité de de bien participer de
bien estce que vous ferez des portes
ouvertes he les gens pouront venir
directement à gu encore dans vos
ateliers il y a le site internet
d'ailleurs 25 créations qui qui qui
s'affiche si vous voulez en savoir un
petit peu plus quelle est votre
formation bon
formation il a rien à voir avec ce que
je fais et je suis dans la relation
internationale fin dans la science
politique et et en fait je me suis
lancée dans dans dans cette entreprise
parce que bon je j'étudiaé dans une
école religieuse et nous nous nous
faisons tout tout tous les métiers t les
VTI manuel et et je me suis dit pourquoi
pas on pour pas me lancer dans la partie
des création c'est ce que je j'aime
beaucoup ces parti et et en fait bon
c'est c'est un hobby mais mais mais
maintenant c'est c'est mon entreprise et
ça devient ça devient mon travail et
effectivement bon ça marche bien et
comment vous travaillez en quelques mots
par exemple pour créer les bijoux que
que vous avez ramené bon j'utilise
plusieurs matériaux et j'utilise le
métal et l'argent et j'utilise aussi des
perles chromatiques et et les Brones et
dans les écharpes bon vous vous voyez et
je vous laisse la présenter voilà juste
devant la cam montre ça ça c'est pour
les femmes c'est c'est un dessign
original et c'est unique et ça c'est en
fait de la des laine
et il y a une tendance maintenant qui
s'appelle frou frou bon mais moi j'ai
fait une écharpe cube je je vais essayer
comme ça vous vous pouvez regarder c'est
comme ça qui qui on l' misis et et c'est
pour les femmes qui qui qui l'aime la
l'originalité et parce que normalement
les femmes eu il voulaient pas euh
être commune et il faut il il il faut
pour nous pour pour faire se remarquer
et et et être différent pour se
démarquer il ne faut pas hésiter à se
tourner vers tous ces artistes qui
pratiquent C ces métiers d'art et ils
sont nombreux portes ouvertes dans vos
hôteliers à Guill encs portes ouvertes
et des parcours pour les découvrir aussi
en dans le parc de la haute vallée de de
Chevreuse à quelques pas de 50 an en
Eveline les métiers d'art vous les
mettez en avant régulièrement tout au
long de l'année il y a aussi une
opération qui se déroulera fin avril 20
et 21 avril av Salon des métiers d'art à
Châteaufort au domaine d'or où le parc
organise à l'aide des artisans d'art de
la haute vallée de
chevvreuse pendant 2 jours des visites
enfin il présentent les produits qu'ils
font il y a aussi certaines
démonstrations et ils essayent de de
valoriser leur savoir-faire il y aura
tout type de de métiers d'artisans qui
seront présents on retrouve tout types
de d'artisanat sur cette Vallet de Chev
oui tout à fait patchwork
ferronier il y a énormément oui
d'artisans d'art qui sont très qui sont
qui ne sont pas connus et la plupart du
temps les gens vont en province parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est à cet endroit
qui trouve des artisans d'art alors
qu'en fait on a à proximité et cette
manifestation est gratuite et ouverte au
public petit et grand 21 avril Salon des
métiers d'art auparavant pour en savoir
plus déjà sur ce qui se passe du côté de
la vallée de Chevreuse il y aura ces
journée européenne auxquell vous
participez avec des portes ouvertes et
puis ces deux parcours pédestres et puis
cyclistes également pour ceux qui sont
peut-être un petit peu plus sportifs
merci à toutes les deux d'êtreevenenu
journée européenne des métiers d'art
c'est jusqu'au 7 avril il y a forcément
une animation à côté de chez vous
culture toujours et cette opération
soigner le décrochage scolaire par le
théâtre c'est une initiative menée pour
la 2e année consécutive par le collège
sainte- Thérèse au Ménil saint-enis des
élèves de 4e ont préparé Germinal de
Zola ils sont en pleine répétition nous
sommes allés les rencontrer
le théâtre pour redonner confiance en
soi et en l'école le collège sainte-
Thérèse du Ménil saintny a mise en place
pour la 2e année consécutive une
représentation théâtrale pour la 4e à
projet une classe réservée aux élèves
qui ont des difficultés dans les
processus d'apprentissage ils sont
intégrés dans une pièce aménagée pour
eux adapté du roman germinal d'Émile
Zola il fallait qu'on trouve une œuvre
qui soit une œuvre de groupe et une
œuvre qui soit du programme de France FR
et aussi à laquelle on puisse rattacher
toutes les disciplines et que voilà
cette œuvre là s'y prêtait
particulièrement par rapport à tout le
travail de en EPS le travail en physique
chimie sur le travail de la mine le
travail en SVT sur la germination sur
voilà toute la naissance des plantes et
puis après tous les parallèles avec en
espagnol travail sur les grèves en
Espagne en anglais les grèves sur toute
l'époque tcher avant d'intégrer la
classe les élèves ont signé un contrat
d'engagement et ont fait part de le
motivation l'objectif du projet
reprendre de l'assurance en ses
capacités tout en respectant le
programme scolaire quand on est en
théâre on a plus de possibilités de de
courir de on est plus on est un peu plus
libre mais faut toujours se concentrer
sur le texte en fait on noublie jamais
que l'école ça sert vraiment à ça et
qu'on est là et ben qu'on va représenter
dans une semaine alors faut toujours se
concentrer on fait pas les imbécile pour
préparer le spectacle les adolescents
sont partis à valers sur le site minier
où Claude Berry a tourné germinal avec
Gérard pardieu ils ont été acteurs le
temps d'un
courtmétrage représentation à découvrir
ce
vendredi